and Greg joins us on loan from CBS
Sports NBA TV hi Greg all right so you
got all the information here like tell
me your final four
oh I haven't picked the Final Four yet I
know you you're gonna find that hard to
believe did give you a final four
yesterday Steve Curren without Arizona
yeah he he gave me his top five schools
okay yeah so he was more concerned with
dancing around the Knicks job he was
giving me his final four we had a lot of
conversation about his potential future
job this past weekend call it a Big Ten
championship okay if you were running
TNT would you start taking resumes for
Steve Kerr's job at the network that's a
great question
I would you know I think anytime you run
a huge corporation it's always advisable
to have some tendency plans in place
okay so if I were I would absolutely
have contingency plans in place because
you just you know you just never know
well you played in New York and I know
that you can tell people about New York
it's it's like when you live in New York
and you want to tell people about New
York people have their opinion already
made up if you're like does Steve know
what he would get into just coaching in
New York let alone coaching in the NBA
does one you know he playing Chicago for
a lot of years so you you get and then
you know as well they might Chicago is a
similar dynamic to New York in terms of
the passion as a sports city
particularly as a pro sport city you
know they they cover all the bases they
want to win as bad as anybody of course
they they want a little more than most
when he was there but I do think he has
an understanding of that of how to deal
with pressures well guys won multiple
championships he's playing on great
teams not just in Chicago in San Antonio
he played on a great team in college
he's been around
they'll gain forever so I don't think
that's an issue honestly it's just more
matter does it make time at this stage
of one's life and I think ultimately
that Steve wants to be a head coach and
I've got to believe that he's going to
have a conversation with the president
of the point about the potential of that
coming to realization here or before
next season if you could coach the
Lakers of the Knicks right now who would
you coach who I would say and I gotta
say this without bias because listen I
grew up a Laker fan as a kid but I do
think that the Knicks might have a
better situation and I say that only
because I probably even though he's
never run a team would trust Phil
Jackson more than I would trust Jim bus
what about snow what's happened over the
last couple years
what about 76ers if you could coach the
Sixers Lakers or Knicks right now
anybody wants to coach the fixers right
now yeah but there's a lotta you got you
got some talent come in here tell me
what you got okay
well I know but you've got to put up
with that to get to you know the lottery
you know the key is you got to get one
of those top two picks in the lottery
well to you dad in all seriousness this
is not a transcended Draft like everyone
talks about this trap it's a good draft
there's some really talented players but
you're not gonna have guys who are gonna
come in and change the course of your
franchise in the next couple of years
like you don't have a LeBron James in
this dress you don't have a Tim Duncan
you don't have a guy that's gonna come
in and double your win total you know
like people don't have a good
perspective think about how good
microcar Williams has been this year
he's gonna be rookie to here probably
yeah
and they brought 21 consecutive games
well they do you know just gotta get a
young player you're gonna get a young
player who you know as talented as he is
he's still young these guys these kids
right
aren't ready to change your the face of
your franchise you're gonna lose a lot
of games that year I don't get unless
you're a playoff game you get the first
date but if you put the top two picks
the team's they go to I don't think
they're gonna be very good next year but
would you rather have the possibility
promise or would you rather have those
you know heavy contracts that the Knicks
have and even the Lakers have some of
those as well so you can clearly both
those teams are but but they're both
those teams have the opportunity to get
good really quick first and foremost
free agents will want to play in both
places okay there's the lure of the
Lakers and then there's the lure of Phil
Jackson in New York so you're gonna have
much more of an opportunity to
participate in trade
both teams are going to be able to get a
max guy after next season okay
both teams are gonna have a lot of money
coming off the books this year so you
you have a lot better opportunity to get
good quick in LA in New York than you do
in Philly you know that's that's those
are gonna be that's a challenge in
Philadelphia there's a case for a lot of
these teams that aren't very good at the
end of the day you've got to have a
great player from which to start and at
least in the Lakers and the next case
they both have a great player that you
know Kobe's a little older obviously but
at least you have something to start
with you don't have that in Philly in
some of these other situations he's Greg
Anthony from CBS Sports NBA TV joining
us courtesy of a UPS and the folks we
use stats LLC they're great they help us
with our stat of the day joining us here
on the Dan Patrick show when it comes to
the tournament here the media is never
right you know you know they don't they
don't get it right when they go
everybody loves Michigan State which
makes me nervous
cuz now everybody loves Michigan State
love the coach but when somebody says
that in the office boy I love Michigan
State you know what I say can you name
two players on the team and the thing is
they know but they they're they're
they're really good and I go okay they
can name Tom Izzo I'm trying to figure
this out of what is the true
I guess opinion or strength of a team if
you're great at the end of the year
like the Michigan State or you've been
consistent through the entire year if
you're the committee well what would you
value more consistent in a consistency
or that they were great for two weeks at
the end of the year in terms of putting
together a bracket yes I will say this I
think and that's a great question
because this is where I think there's a
disconnect for the fans the way you're
supposed to see this is my philosophy
you don't pick the four best teams as
one seeds you reward the four teams that
had the best seasons and so that's why
if you look at Florida Arizona you look
at where Virginia was a bit was able to
do in Wichita State but to me they had
the four best seasons you know I mean
they had the best seasons Florida won
the conference and the tournament and
they had some quality wins
non-conference Arizona similarly they
didn't win the conference tournament but
they had some really good wins
non-conference they also lost one of
their best players and were able to
rebound and they won over 30 games
Wichita State we talked about a 34 wins
I don't care who you went 34 consecutive
in college and going to feed it there's
a reason you deserve it a one seed in
Virginia similarly you know they proved
it they didn't have you know the
imbalance schedule and HDC hurts you a
little bit but they did rally they
didn't beat Duke in that tournament
championship game and I was kind of an
exclamation point for them and I think
the fact that Michigan lost the Michigan
State is the reason they ended up
getting the 1 seed so I think that's how
you look at it even though those are the
4-1 seeds I think you can make a case
for a Louisville a Michigan State if
Kansas is healthy I think they're in
their conversation and Michigan even you
know and then other teams that you could
say are equally as good it's just that
they weren't rewarded that's the thing
with Louisville like people are up in an
upload our logo and I get it to a
certain extent because I do think
they're much better team in the foresee
but they didn't have a quality non
confident you know they had
opportunities they lost all those games
and so that's my point about how the
committee looks at it they're ranking
what you're the value of your season
they're trying to reward the
teams that had the best seasons as
opposed to identify then they say the
tournament will identify the best team
we're just rewarding the teams that had
the best seasons and now let's go play
the tournament and if you're the best
team you're gonna win the turn but I
still Kansas doesn't have Joel embiid
who's a great players so they're not a
great team going into the tournament
doesn't mean they won't do damage or
when they getting back but I I have to
value I want the best product on display
as the as the top seeds
that's where Louisville has played great
Michigan State has played great
Villanova has not played great
you know there's certain teams like st.
Louis got a higher seat I just think
what you're doing at the end of the year
should have more value because you want
the top seeds to do well you want the
big names to do well the teams playing
well I if you did well in December you
know or you know whenever a preseason
tournament or something it shouldn't
count as much in my opinion is what you
do at the end of the year but that just
might take the momentum building in it's
a great point you gotta also do you play
the whole season it's no different than
football when in the NFL when they feed
you some things are playing much better
the second half of the season than they
did the first half but the record is the
totality of the season is it not but
Michigan State got healthy Greg they I
have to factor in that they weren't
healthy the seeding is based on the
season not on what I think like I think
I think I thought coming into the year
they were my picture to get to the Final
Four and potentially win it you know
they were ranked I think in the top
three but you know they finished second
in their conference about three games
and yeah the injuries play a role but
that's why they're not seeded one that
doesn't mean they won't have an
opportunity to win it III don't think
you can then and even in st. Louis's
case but st. Louis won the Atlantic and
they got to be pretty good they stopped
young so I get that it's hard with the
seeding that's why that's why you got to
use the TPI yeah see that's this is got
this you're the perfect person for the
team performance index because see now
because you like
just focus on on the quality and in the
consistency and the efficiency of a team
right and and forget about well this guy
wasn't there and so but but this is
where the team is now and that's the
beauty of this whole thing the TPI it's
funny you look at the top five teams
they're they're Florida Arizona Wichita
State Louisville and then Virginia so
for the top five oh one seeds and again
it's telling you about the teams that
have been the most efficient and
consistent this year but at the end of
the day you still gotta go play
you're not going to avoid playing good
teams in the tournament yeah I agree so
you know all this stuff we're gonna find
out and I will say this about the
tournament and you know this as well as
anybody more often than not the best
team doesn't win it all right before I
let you go will a one-seed win the
championship yes or no no no okay but
you were referencing the best team
doesn't always win the championship
you're talking about Duke when you NLB
lost a Duke that that second year is
that what you're saying you hate or go
ahead good to visit with you thanks for
joining us Greg Greg Anthony CBS Sports
NBA TV